hey youtubers is Charlie so big news
Marvel finally confirmed Doctor Strange
for thor ragnarok so we got to talk
about what's going on and how he's going
to help him out with the infinity gems
in Odin there is a new round of the
spider-man giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video be sure to click
that Bell to enable alerts so that you
don't miss anything so awesome news that
they finally confirmed Doctor Strange
for thor ragnarok big team-up they said
that he be very important to the movie
so based on the Doctor Strange
post-credit scene we can guess that at
least he'll be helping find Odin that's
what I liked the beginning of it so he
was seen like somewhere floating around
the set looking like a hobo when they
were filming this post-credit scene so
for some reason Odin is stuck on earth
and seemingly does not know who he is
so when Thor is talking to dr. strange
about why he brought Loki to the earth
to find Odin he just says family drama
which is a pretty good summation of
their relationship just a lot of drama
so it sounds like Loki just made a deal
with hella to banish Odin to earth and
somehow separate him from his power or
block his power because the odinforce
makes him one of the most powerful
beings in the universe so it sounds like
the most effective way of doing that is
just confusing him and making him forget
that he's Odin he doesn't have his
powers but we'll see how the movie
explains that because the odinforce is
basically like his life force is
actually made of the life force of
Odin's two brothers that died fighting
Fire Lord
Serdar so that's like when the odinforce
became a thing and it gets a little
complicated but the movies usually find
simple ways of explaining that but it
sounds like thor ragnarok is going to be
amazingly weird so even though they'll
find an easy way to explain things
they're not going to dumb it down or
just like completely wash over a really
cool comic book stuff so I have complete
faith but it sounds like what's
happening is is a whole bunch of stuff
has transpired like all this Odin Loki
drama happened that led up to them
seeking out dr. Strange's help and then
their search for Odin starts somewhere
early in the film because the main
action of Thor Ragnarok is going to be
Hellas incursion in takeover of Asgard
from her realm he'll so she's basically
leading this legion in with
help of Carl Urban's scourge that's
actually gonna be really interesting new
character Karl Urban is not a small
actor so we haven't talked a lot about
him but once we get our first trailer
which I'll talk about in a second we'll
get a better idea of how he's going to
fit into the movie but he's basically a
lieutenant of hellas it sounds like he
might end up switching sides at the end
of the film remains to be seen
because Marvel has this new thing where
they're doing like really morally gray
characters that aren't just like
completely evil or completely good which
i think makes for really great
storytelling so I'm expecting some
surprises from Karl Urban Scare achter
but cate blanchett has actually been
photographed on set she is gonna kick so
much ass as hella and she is so powerful
there's no way that they're going to be
able to kill her at the end of the film
it'll be like a Red Skull situation
where either they banish her to another
realm because remember Red Skull is
still floating around in outer space
somewhere whether or not Marvel ever
wants to bring him back or I'm really
hoping that Ella comes back around
during infinity war and becomes Marvel's
version of death because she rules over
the Asgardian plane of death the place
where people go if they don't go to
Valhalla so I'm hoping that the movie
doesn't change that from the comics
because it's basically help for
Asgardian characters and if it sounds a
little weird it's just because as
Guardians exist on a different plane of
existence like they exist in our
universe the movies have simplified that
a little bit but technically they don't
exist in outer space with us like if you
had a spaceship
you couldn't just fly to Asgard that's
why you have to use the Rainbow Bridge
to get there but because Loki is magic
it sounds like there's some sort of
enchantment that was laid on Odin to
block him from his power
that's where Doctor Strange comes in
just taking advantage of the fact that
he keeps track of all magical beings
that are on earth or like people from
other dimensions basically like a giant
[ __ ] list of anybody that could
potentially cause trouble and has powers
the second big reason why Doctor Strange
is really important is because the
absence of Odin leaves this vacuum of
knowledge so what is Doctor Strange to
what do we see him do in the movie he
reads a lot of books he learned about
one of the infinity gems the time gem so
what was Thor doing in like the funny
comic-con trailer that they released
where he was hanging out with Daryl he
was trying
to figure out the Infinity stones in
what was going on with Thanos so even
though Thor is a pretty smart guy
there's just a gap in his knowledge when
it comes to infinity gems the Doctor
Strange can help fill like he has a
giant library that goes back eons so
there's got to be some more information
on the infinity gems in there somewhere
but the way they've been talking about
the behind-the-scenes stuff Ford or
Ragnarok just makes it sound like most
of the film will just be Thor budding up
with the Hulk and Loki eventually in
Doctor Strange will just be a smaller
part of it just a very very important
part though because if they're going to
unleash Ragnarok which is basically an
event in Asgardian history from the
comics I'm talking about Jack Kirby's
Ragnarok not the Ragnarok Thor duplicate
cyborg from Civil War the monsters of
Ragnarok are like way more than Thor and
even Hulk could handle by themselves so
that's where Odin comes in you really
need the odinforce to fight all of these
monsters and if there was any doubt
about how epic that big battle is going
to be it sounds like it's going to be
the big climax of the film they actually
showed off as part of their comic-con
real an image of the Hulk getting ready
to punch fire lord Surtur like this
giant like you know filling the frame
fire being with a tiny looking little
Hulk like that's how big the size
difference was so just think about the
idea of Hulk vs. fire lord Surtur's they
were really just hyping that up that
might not actually end up in the movie
they just want to let you know that like
hey all this [ __ ] is going to be going
down we're going to do all the weird
things that we were afraid to do in the
first two Thor movies because there was
a rumor that they were actually going to
do fire Lord's surgery during Thor the
dark world but you do actually get a
peek at his realm when like the nine
realms start to align all the big
portals in the Dark Elves are going to
try and use the aether the reality gem
to alter reality so yay for fire Lords
Serdar but really just the idea of like
changing reality we'll come back around
during infinity war this is actually the
scene where Odin explains the infinity
gems and how that reality gem works to
change reality the are relics that
predate the universe itself what lies
within her
appears to be one of them nine realms
and not eternal
they had a dawn as they will have a dusk
but before that dorm the dark forces
Dark Elves reigned absolute and
unchallenged borne of eternal night for
Dark Elves come to steal away the light
I know this stories mother told him to
us his children they leader Malekith
made a weapon out of that darkness and
it was called the ether while the other
relics often appear as stones the ether
is fluid and ever-changing it changes
matter into dark matter it seeks out
host bodies drawing strength from their
life force
Malekith sought to use the Aether's
power to return the universe to one of
darkness
but after eternities of bloodshed
my father Baal finally triumphed
ushering in a peace that lasted
thousands of years what happened he
killed them all so you just get the idea
there are a couple really old really
powerful people around the Marvel
Universe like the collector one of the
Ancients of the universe as well as Odin
who is ancient in his own way very
powerful who know exactly what's going
on with the infinity gems and just
somehow aren't readily available or
aren't on the team with the heroes so to
speak so you have people like dr.
strange that need to step in and fill
that gap like oh you heard about the man
with a purple glove in the floating
chair that's who this is this is what
he's trying to do this is what these
gems are capable of if you were to wield
even two of them at the same time it
would be catastrophic lest he wield them
all at the same time so it'll be fun to
see how Doctor Strange treats the idea
of Thanos after he's dealt with Dormammu
in the time gem like he's probably
riding pretty high and even though he's
not quite as much of an ass as he was at
the beginning of Doctor Strange like the
dr. Stephen strange to sorcerer supreme
mellows him out just a little bit but
he's still kind of high on himself the
way that Tony Stark is high on himself
so just expect a lot of humor
are in the tone of what you saw in that
Thor post-credit scene during dr.
strange just a lot of really dry wit in
Thor just kind of nodding his head and
going along with it like oh yeah this is
like the least strange thing that I've
heard today growing up in Asgard like
there are a lot of tales that they talk
about like the Warriors three going off
just having adventures that we haven't
really seen on-screen so you get the
sense that there's not a lot of stuff in
the nine realms that surprises Thor but
like you heard during that Odin clip a
lot of this history he got as children's
stories read to him by Frigga so there's
probably a lot that he doesn't totally
believe like oh I heard this big story
about Fire Lord sir I heard this tale
about father and his brothers banished
him to a different realm but like you
tell children's stories about monsters
under their bed the Ragnarok monsters
are the monsters under Thor's bed and
they are very very real like the Midgard
serpent trapped inside the earth which
was a real disappointment they decided
not to do that during Thor the dark
world so all that stuff is coming back
for thor ragnarok Fenris wolf fire Lord
sir
the Midgard serpent and probably just
like a whole bunch of other Horrors from
the nine realms in the tone of the
guardians of the galaxy monster that we
saw in that trailer which is James Gunn
explains it is not the Shoom agora they
know a lot of people were wondering
about that because it had all those
tentacles it's just an interdimensional
being that the guardians are hired to
get rid of so I'll talk more about that
when I do another guardians video but
it's not Shoom Agora that will probably
come back in the Doctor Strange sequel
so once we get through some of these
other Marvel movies and some more Doctor
Strange cameos we can talk more about
the Doctor Strange sequel because they
have talked about doing Clea as well as
shuma gorath but that's so far off it's
just a little early to start talking
about it now for the meantime Doctor
Strange will just be Thor's Wikipedia
while Odin has been sidelined what's
going to happen next is I have some new
agents of shield life model decoy
footage that I'll post I'll do a trailer
video for that and I'm expecting some
new flash footage to drop well you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
to rewatch that funny thor trailer and
you can click here to learn about all
the awesome stuff that's coming this
year so happy about 2017 so let's
high-five I'll see you guys tonight
you